est-ce que vous avez déjà calculer votre
empreinte carbone
j'ai mesuré la mienne récemment et j'ai
voulu la comparer à l'empreinte carbone
moyenne d'un français
voici à quoi cette empreinte carbone
moyenne ressemble j'ai retrouvé les
postes dont on parle habituellement dans
le débat public
les transports l'alimentation
le logement et le chauffage les achats
et puis j'ai vu ses 2 colonnes en gris à
droite qui pèse quand même pour 15 % de
l'empreinte carbone des français
la dépense publique
je suis moi-même fonctionnaires et
pourtant j'en avais assez peu entendu
parler
faut-il décarbonés l'administration
publique à quelle vitesse comment est ce
qu'on fait
j'ai voulu en savoir plus j'ai creusé et
de fil en aiguille j'ai fini par co
écrire avec un ping pong qui s'appelle
le chief project un rapport de 400 pages
sur le sujet
c'est donc un vaste sujet mais vous
allez le voir c'est aussi un sujet
passionnant est un sujet très important
mais de quoi parle-t-on précisément
depuis les écoles les collèges les
lycées les universités jusqu'aux
hôpitaux publics
en passant par l'armée les casernes de
pompiers les musées les mairies ou
encore le service de ramassage et de
traitement des déchets
l'administration publique regroupe des
sous secteurs très différents
mais tous est essentielle dans notre
quotidien
éducation santé
défense
propreté culture
ce n'est quand même pas rien
en quelques mots l'administration
publique ces six millions d'agents soit
20% de l'emploi en france
c'est 200 milliards de commandes
publiques soit 10% du pib et 15 % de
l'empreinte carbone des français comme
on l'a vu précédemment
et en fait ne pourront pas bénéficier de
tous les services publics sans des
bâtiments sans les transports et 100 dh
et des bâtiments qui utilisent
majoritairement de l'énergie fossile
pour leur construction et surtout pour
leur chauffage le refroidissement
pensez aux établissements publics et
vous avez fréquenté de la maternelle
jusqu'à l'université
à la mairie de votre commune
ou encore à la piscine municipale
nous ne pourrions pas ne plus bénéficier
des services publics sont des transports
des transports qui nous permette à tout
citoyen de nous rendre jusqu'au service
public et aux agents publics qui ont
besoin de se déplacer pour réaliser leur
mission en fait ces transports dépendent
aussi majoritairement énergies fossiles
notamment du pétrole
on peut penser aux policiers municipaux
qui effectuent des rondes pour assurer
le maintien de l'ordre public ou encore
aux pompiers appelés en urgence
et finalement nous ne pourrions pas
bénéficié de ses services publics sont
des achats des achats alimentaires pour
approvisionner les cantines des
établissements publics et des achats de
matériel par exemple des chars d'assaut
ou des avions de combat pour notre âme
le fonctionnement de l'administration à
l'image de ceux de notre société est
donc aujourd'hui majoritairement
dépendant des énergies fossiles
et ça ça pose deux problèmes majeurs
le premier de ces problèmes c'est la
dépendance à d'autres pays on parle
beaucoup en ce moment du gaz et du
pétrole russes
mais nous pourrions avoir le même type
de débat avec d'autres régions du monde
alors même que ces ressources sont
amenés à se raréfier
notre dépendance
géopolitiques et économiques à leurs
énergies fossiles en provenance d'autres
pays est une menace à la résilience de
l'administration publique et donc à sa
capacité à nous assurer à nos citoyens
ces services publics essentiels
de ce goût de ses problèmes
c'est que les énergies fossiles sont
responsables d'émissions de gaz à effet
de serre qui contribuent au changement
climatique qu'il est chaque jour
plusieurs gens de limiter
ses émissions de gaz à effet de serre
proviennent du charbon et pétrole du gaz
des problèmes également de l'élevage
d'animaux principalement des bovins qui
sont consommés dans les cantines des
établissements publics
c'est donc un problème
car avec seulement un réchauffement de
1,1 degré de la température moyenne à la
surface de la terre on assiste déjà à
des événements météorologiques plus
intense plus extrême est plus frais dans
quelques exemples en 2021 des méga-feux
en australie ou au canada
des inondations mortelles en europe une
aggravation de la famine à madagascar
sous l'effet de la sécheresse et j'en
passe
un récent rapport du giec le groupe
d'experts intergouvernemental sur
l'évolution du climat qui fait le
consensus scientifique sur les questions
climatiques
nous explique aujourd'hui 3,3 milliards
d'humains
sont exposés aux risques climatiques
c'est près d'une personne sur deux sur
notre planète
et la france ne sera pas épargnée elle
est d'ailleurs d'ores et déjà touchés
et pour ne pas dépasser des seuils au
delà desquels le réchauffement
climatique pourrait s'emballer et
provoqué des dégâts irréversibles
les scientifiques nous explique que nous
devons diminuer très rapidement nos
émissions d'au moins 5 s'emparant
une réduction de 5% par an c'est que
nous avons connu au cours de l'année
oui cette même année où nous avons passé
deux mois aux fines et dans un rayon de
1 km autour de chez nous
et plus nous attendons plus nous devons
diminuer rapidement nos émissions
ou alternativement plus les conséquences
seront graves
vous êtes inquiet
moi aussi et c'est normal mais cette
inquiétude ne va pas être pour nous un
frein à l'action au contraire elle doit
nous donner envie d'aider carboni et est
décarbonée en particulier
l'administration publique
il est donc urgent de s'attaquer à ce
problème
afin d'assurer la continuité du service
public dans un monde sans énergie
fossile et de contribuer à la neutralité
carbone de la france en diminuant
directement les émissions de
l'administration bien sûr mais aussi
encore plus importante et c'est là que
ça devient vraiment intéressant en
entraînant le réseau l'économie dans cet
élan
l'administration publique a cette
capacité
grâce à la commande publique
c'est à dire les achats effet vis-à-vis
des autres secteurs
car sa capacité à montrer l'exemple et à
communiquer une vision positive de la
décarbonation
et aussi grâce aux politiques publiques
qui elle peut mettre en oeuvre pour
inciter ou contraindre les autres
secteurs
ces politiques publiques d'ailleurs
seront d'autant plus pertinente que
l'administration aura appris de sa
propre décarbonation
c'est pourquoi nous pouvons affirmer
qu'une détermination bien ordonnée
commence par soi même
ce pouvoir d'entraînement c'est une
capacité que nous pas les autres
secteurs
ce qui en fait un privilège pour
l'administration publique mais aussi ce
que d'accord avec moi une responsabilité
et très concrètement de quel levier on
dispose
on peut schématiquement les séparer en
deux grandes familles
d'abord des leviers par sous secteur
ensuite des leviers transfert si nous en
dit un peu plus les leviers par sous
secteur peuvent être catégorisés selon
qui s'applique aux bâtiments aux
transports à l'alimentation ou aux
achats de matériel pour chacune de ces
grandes familles je vais vous donner une
action qui me semblent prioritaires
même s'il y en a beaucoup d'autres
les bâtiments d'abord
il ya évidemment le chantier de la
rénovation énergétique
c'est un vaste programme qui a déjà
commencé qui ne va pas assez vite il
faut donc largement accéléré mais
j'aimerais surtout insisté sur les
comportements de sobriété
c'est à dire les changements d'usagé qui
permettent de diminuer nos besoins en
énergie très concrètement il s'agit de
chauffer moins les bâtiments en hiver et
d'accepter d'avoir plus chaud en été
c'est un biais qui loin d'être
négligeable en effet on estime qu'on
peut économiser jusqu'à 10 % de la
consommation énergétique d'un bâtiment
si on diminue la température de 1 degré
en hiver
ce n'est pas rien et on peut rester dans
la limite du raisonnable si on adapte un
peu les codes vestimentaires
notons qu'il existe déjà
des consignes à ses strictes sur la
température dans les bâtiments publiques
mais elles ne sont pas toujours
respectées
ensuite sur les transports une action
qui me semble prioritaire c'est de
recourir davantage à des modes de
transport bas carbone pour les agents
qui doivent se déplacer depuis chez eux
jusque là où ils exercent leur métier et
aussi pour réaliser leur mission
je pense notamment au recours aux
mobilités active le vélo qu'ils soient
électriques ou mécaniques la marche à
pied ou bien le covoiturage des
transports en commun ou encore pourquoi
pas les voitures électriques
à condition qu'elles soient petites donc
légère et peu gourmande en énergie
pour mener à bien ce changement il faut
inciter financièrement les agents
publics aujourd'hui il existe un forfait
mobilité durable
mais seulement pour une partie des
agents ceux qui travaillent pour l'état
et tous ceux qui travaillent pour les
collectivités territoriales ou les
hôpitaux n'en bénéficient pas
nécessairement
ensuite de mettre en place des
infrastructures adaptées les pistes
cyclables des parkings à vélos sécurisé
des bornes de recharge électrique et
finalement on peut rénover
intelligemment les flottes de véhicules
bus mais qui
pour l'alimentation une action qui est
prioritaire
c'est de diminuer la consommation de
viande et de poisson
en effet
ces deux aliments sont responsables de
50 % de l'empreinte carbone moyenne de
l'alimentation des français
aujourd'hui certaines cantines
d'établissements publics sont obligés de
proposer un menu végétarien une fois par
semaine
on pourrait étendre cette obligation
pour qu'elles soient obligées de
proposer une option végétarienne au
moins une fois par jour
et pour mener à bien ce changement il
faut un accompagnement de grande ampleur
des acteurs de la restauration
collective
et ensuite
il ya la question des achats de matériel
là quelque chose qui me semble
prioritaire c'est de l'utiliser bien
davantage les matériaux réutilisés ou
recyclés
pour que ça marche il faut former les
acheteurs publics et leur fournir des
guides et des référentiels à berthez
concernant les leviers transverses je
vous en donne 3 le premier c'est de
mesurer
d'après vous parmi les bâtiments les
établissements publics qui sont
aujourd'hui soumis à l'obligation de
réaliser leur bilan carbone combien le
font effectivement
seulement 26% c'est à dire à peine un
sur quatre et encore du chemin à
parcourir
ensuite il ya la question de la
formation il faudrait former tous les
agents publics
à l'urgence climatique et aux moyens d'y
répondre et on pourrait commencer par
les dirigeants publics c'est à dire les
élus maires députés sénateurs
et les dirigeants d'administrations
cette formation pourrait se dérouler en
deux temps
d'abord un temps de sensibilisation pour
expliquer l'urgence d'agir et de donner
envie d'y aller ensuite une formation au
levier d'action afin de permettre à tout
un chacun de mener des actions efficaces
et finalement il ya la question de la
planification
c'est important pour mettre en musique
pour orchestrer tous les changements
dont on parle
par exemple on pourrait imaginer que
chaque ministère soient tenus de publier
un plan de décarbonation à trois ou cinq
ans
et que le ministre correspondants
et à tenir compte
chaque année publiquement de l'atteinte
des objectifs associés
finalement ce qu'on voit à travers
toutes ces explications c'est que le
problème de la transition bas carbone de
l'administration comme c'est le cas pour
beaucoup d'autres secteurs ce n'est pas
tant de savoir ce que nous devons faire
et si nous savons le faire mais plutôt
comment on peut le faire plus vite et à
plus grand défi
est dans cette salle vous qu'est ce que
vous pouvez faire
d'abord vous pouvez parler autour de
vous à vos amis à vos collègues à votre
famille sur les réseaux sociaux
vous pouvez en parler à vous élus locaux
à votre mère
à votre député si vous les croisez bingo
et sinon vous leur envoyez une lettre ou
un email
ensuite en cette période électorale vous
pouvez vous renseigner sur la volonté
des candidats et candidates à l'élection
présidentielle aux élections
législatives à faire de la décarbonation
où vous ré priorité
et finalement
si comme moi vous êtes un agent public
alors félicitations
vous avez gagné le droit d'être
exemplaires et de lancer un groupe de
travail en interne pour décarbonés votre
service
et à l'arrivée à paris ça ressemblerait
une administration décarbonée est ce que
ça donne envie
imaginez
des écoles des collèges des lycées
universités mairie qui sont rénovés plus
accueillant plus vivant
imaginez la police municipale qui se
déplace à vélo des bennes à ordure
électrique
imaginé dans les cantines des
établissements publics une alimentation
plus équilibrée plus localement plus
saines et respectueuses de
l'environnement
une administration publique
qui joue le rôle de locomotive de la
décarbonation et entraîne le réseau
l'économie dans son élan
une administration publique qui
communiquent ils nous visions positives
de la transition bas carbone
une administration publique dont les
agents sont fiers une administration
publique plus dynamique aux yeux de tous
ça donne envie alors pourquoi attendre
des carbonneau l'administration publique
[Applaudissements]